[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIKO SCHROER: My
name is Niko Schroer.
I'm a partner manager in
the Play App partnerships
team in Berlin, Germany, and
it's my absolute pleasure
to be here with
all of you today.
JEENA JAMES: Did you guys have
fun at the concert last night?
[CHEERING]
Me too.
And I have a sore
throat to prove it.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Jeena.
I'm on the Play Apps
partnerships team
here in Mountain View.
Like Niko, I'm super
excited to welcome you here
to our session--
Tools and Tips to Boost User
Engagement and Retention.
I/O 2017 has been
incredibly exciting,
with a lot of great
announcements.
We heard that the
Android ecosystem
has grown tremendously, with
the number of developers that
have over a million
monthly installs that have
grown 35% in the last year.
There are 2 billion monthly
active Android devices today.
And people have
downloaded 82 billion apps
from the Play Store.
That's amazing, and it's all the
hard work that you have put in.
So give yourself a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
In the last three days, we have
had so many really inspiring
conversations with developers
such as yourselves here at I/O,
and they have come
and told us how
they're excited
for this session,
because boosting engagement
within their apps
is one of the most
important topics for them.
NIKO SCHROER: And we
find it exciting indeed.
We, of course, completely agree
that boosting user engagement
is a key topic.
If you quickly-- or
if you all quickly
recall Sunday's
keynote on Wednesday,
actually he talked about the
reach and also the engagement
that our own products are seeing
within the first, probably,
three minutes of the keynote.
But then talking about
user engagement today,
it's also very humbling, because
optimizing for user engagement
is a constant challenge
for developers.
We totally understand that.
And I think we can all agree
that boosting user engagement
is not a tool.
It's not a single tip.
It's not even a
single best practice.
It's the combination
of a lot of things
that have to be done right, and
have to be constantly optimized
in order for it to work.
So from our daily work with
developers in different regions
and with different
backgrounds, we
know that even for the
smartest developers,
staying on top of all of
these details all the time
can be very hard.
So that is why in
today's sessions,
we want to do the following.
We're going to give
you a holistic overview
of proven best practices
on how to boost
user engagement and apps.
And to underline that we
are not making this up,
we actually have examples from
some of the leading developers
around the world this
year with you, and to show
that it actually works.
So Jeena, shall we
take a look at what
we are going to cover today?
JEENA JAMES: Absolutely.
So it starts with defining
your objective for engagement.
Now, if you do not
know what exactly you
want your users to
engage, you would not
know what you want to boost.
With a clear objective in
mind for improving engagement,
then it's all about testing
which optimization can
increase engagement for you.
NIKO SCHROER: Yeah, and once
you define the optimization
and the engagement
objective, and you've
found a feature
that performs best,
you also want to
release it smartly.
It's very important to
land with your users.
Topic number four we're
going to look at today
is great onboarding.
It's a topic that's really,
really close to my heart.
When it comes to
user engagement,
it's just such a crucial
step in the user's journey.
JEENA JAMES: Also crucial are
smart and successful content
launches, to give your
users exactly what they
are looking for as well
as stimulate greater
and long-term engagement.
And finally, building an
effective communication
strategy, specifically
around notifications.
And that can help drive
further user awareness.
Wow, that's a lot
of things that we're
going to be covering today.
NIKO SCHROER: Yep.
JEENA JAMES: So Niko, do
you want to kick it off
with the first one?
NIKO SCHROER: Sure.
Let's go, right?
Let's unpack this.
So defining your
engagement objective
really starts with something
that sounds very simple,
but yet can be very
tricky to actually get to.
You have to have a
clear idea of what's
your proposition to users.
What is it that makes
your business stand out?
What makes your app or the
service you offer special?
Based on that, how is it that
you actually want your user
to engage with your app?
Let's look at some examples.
Everybody here knows
Airbnb, I guess.
Their value proposition
is to let customers
experience foreign
places in a unique way
by staying with locals.
Accordingly, for
Airbnb, engagement
is measured in nights booked.
And that is what
they optimized for.
EyeEm is a community
by photographers
for photographers.
Their engagement objective is
to get users to upload photos.
EyeEm found that users uploading
one photo on day zero increases
day 7 retention by 2.5x.
Even further, users
uploading eight photos
over the first seven
days can be retained
over a much longer
period of time--
very clear objective that
they can optimize against.
And that works.
At YouTube, it's all
about watch hours,
and so are the optimizations
of the user experience.
And lastly, One
Football, an app that
provides football fans around
the world with live scores
and curated football news, they
look at different engagement
drivers, with the key one
being articles read per user.
So as you can see from
these different examples,
the definition of how to
drive user engagement,
or what use engagement means,
can be quite different.
But what all of these
examples of these developers
have in common is
that they individually
have a very clear idea of
their engagement objective,
and thus how to drive
engagement with their users.
JEENA JAMES: So laying out
a clear engagement objective
is the basis on which you can
optimize the app experience.
You can have plenty of ideas,
larger, smaller features
that you're trying to improve.
But how are you going to
identify which one actually
drives user engagement?
You would have to do
multiple experiments
and run a lot of tests.
Now, start with a hypotheses.
Develop two or more
variants, and set up a test
or run about a
minimum period of time
so that you can get a
statistically significant
result.
Now, individual factors may
vary because of the use cases.
So lets take a look
at it with an example.
One Football, a popular
football app constantly working
towards driving their engagement
goal, as Niko mentioned,
uses reading more articles.
With several feature
options in mind,
they use Firebase
Remote Config, and that
lets them change app
components on the server side,
and they are not making any
updates to the app itself.
They are able to test
different variations
before they release the
best-performing option to all
their users.
Now, in this
particular experiment,
they had three variations.
The winning variation
saw an increase of 5%
in sessions per user,
and also saw an increase
of 6% in articles that
users were reading per user,
as a result that variation was
rolled out to all the users.
But this is a great
example of someone
who did that with a
combination of three things--
the engagement objective
that was really clear,
the ideas that they had for
optimization, and a tool
like Firebase Remote Config
to make it all happen.
NIKO SCHROER: By the way,
the One Football team
is in the audience.
Quick round of applause.
There they are.
[APPLAUSE]
Great job, guys.
So having defined the
objective and run a test
with a successful
result is great.
Now you really want to
make sure not to mess it up
when releasing the feature
to a large set of users.
What do I mean by that?
You want to make sure that
the rollout is actually
technically stable,
and that users actually
notice what has changed.
To make sure that you
land the future release,
just follow a very
simple process.
First, ensure that the new
build is technically stable.
That is just very important.
It was mentioned in
other talks before,
but we see that 50% of
one-star reviews on Google Play
mention topics complaining
about app stability and bugs.
So with that, take as a proxy
for happy or unhappy users,
and then those users
are pretty unhappy.
And it's quite simple--
unhappy users are much harder
to engage and retain, right?
Secondly, leverage
the features you
have on the Play console,
such as alpha and beta groups,
go to soft launch, and then
gradually go to full rollout.
And then for the user,
make sure that you actually
visually guide them to
what's new in the app,
as you can see from the Material
Design example on the slides.
To support you in
this process, we
launched a couple of new
reports in the Play console,
which we strongly
recommend that you use.
They were discussed in depth
in several other talks, which
I recommended to check out.
But just very quickly,
the pre-launch report
now provides developers
with even more test coverage
and understanding of your app.
For example, you
get a great overview
of key screens across devices.
Secondly, the release
dashboard gives you
updates on the release as
it happens with hourly data.
Using both of these
reports is a best practice
to release stable
updates and keeping
users happy and engaged.
If we take Play Store reviews
as a proxy another time,
we see that 60% of users
rating apps with 5 stars
actually praise speed,
design, and usability--
as simple as that.
OK, onto number four,
my favorite topic--
user onboarding.
User onboarding is
a unique opportunity
to learn about
users' preferences
and show them what is
great about your app.
A great example of-- oh, sorry.
So when optimizing
for that, keep
a couple of things in mind.
The onboarding should be
fast, seamless, and immersive.
Ideally, the onboarding
doesn't feel like onboarding.
Ideally it feels like it's
a contextual, core part
of the user experience.
A good example, and you see I
got really excited about that
already, is health and
fitness developer Freeletics.
So Freeletics gets
users really fit
through individualized
workout plans.
About onboarding, the
guys from Freeletics
actually say they
don't onboard users.
They directly and
progressively emerge them
with the experience.
So for new users, the immersive
product experience really
starts with the
onboarding flow, where
it's all about the
results that they want
to achieve using Freeletics.
Based on the onboarding, users
get a customized training plan,
which engages them
as free athletes,
to use the app several times
a week to train and become
fitter and healthier.
Another really cool
example is One Football.
One Football's
onboarding process
is designed to drive engagement
through personalization.
Any football fans
in the audience?
Quick show of hands--
soccer, I'm sorry, soccer fans.
There we go.
So all of you will know what One
Football's research confirms--
real football fans mostly
care about their one team.
So the onboarding experience
of One Football's app
is really optimized for that.
So after downloading
the app, you
select which one is
your favorite team.
I really like Arsenal
London, so I selected them.
On the second
screen, already it's
Arsenal themed, as you
can see by the red color.
As a user, I can now pick
which of Arsenal's competition
I want to follow.
Once I have done
that-- in my case,
I probably selected
all of them--
once I've done that, I'm done.
Now my home screen, which
is what you see now,
really centers about what's
most important to me.
It's the latest
results of Arsenal--
in this case, that we're going
to play Manchester United
a couple weeks back.
Further, my news stream
now really centers
around Arsenal-specific news.
And actually, so do
the push notifications.
So thanks to a fast, very
simple and immersive onboarding
experience, the One
Football experience
is much more
personalized, relevant,
and engaging to their users.
And while it's not a must,
a lot of the advantages
of great onboarding actually
come with offering users
log-in functionality.
For example, if you
really were cross-screen
and you want to save
users' preferences,
log-in is a super useful
thing to have for your users.
But we know that building
an account infrastructure
can be complex and challenging.
So luckily, Google has
two really great solutions
for that.
Let's look at number one.
Google Sign-in lets
users access your app
with their Google login.
In this example, I want
to show you Mobills Labs,
It's a budget planning
app from Brazil.
Offers a super quick
and fast log-in process
using Google Sign-in.
Mobills Labs, are you guys here?
I know they were supposed to.
Ah, there we go.
OK, quick round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Quick shout out.
So after downloading
Mobills, the user
taps to sign in with Google.
They tap to confirm
which account
they want to use from the
Google account selector,
and they're in as
simple as that--
super quick, super fast.
According to the Mobills
CEO, Carlos Terceiro,
log-ins increased by 300% after
implementing Google Sign-in,
and it's now the most popular
choice for logging in.
The second solution Google
offers for developers
to make this very easy is
Smart Lock for Passwords.
With Smart Lock for
Passwords, users
can log into apps using their
credentials they have saved,
which the developers, you, can
retrieve with a specific API.
So the example here, or
there as well, shows Yazio.
Yazio is a
calorie-counting app that
helps its users develop
a healthier lifestyle.
So after my week here,
I ate lots of burgers,
and I want to go back and
live a healthier lifestyle.
So I download Yazio, and from
here, the flow is super simple.
I select my goal,
which is stay healthy.
And after that, Yazio
lets me create an account.
It's very straightforward.
The Smart Lock at
email picker lets
me pick which email I want
to use from my account.
The details are prefilled, and
I only have to add the password,
and I'm done.
I'm in and I can
start using the app.
Implementing Smart
Lock significantly
improved the sign-in
experience for Yazio users,
and saw some great results.
Actually, sign-up
conversions increased by 14%,
and over 70% of those
users used an email address
that was suggested.
I mean, why wouldn't you?
I hate typing in my
email address myself.
So for a personalized
app like Yazio
that really depends on having
my user preferences saved,
this is really crucial to engage
users, and a great example
on how to use Smart
Lock for that.
JEENA JAMES: Thank you.
So the insights that you learn
from your user's preference
during onboarding
that can be leveraged
as you think about
boosting engagement
with successful
content launches.
Now, what do I mean by that?
Game developers
have successfully
done this in the
form of live ops.
Have you heard of
live ops before?
OK, let me tell you.
They are a key focus for game
developers at the moment,
and there are interesting
insights for app developers.
Put simply, live ops is
running games as a service.
Think of it as the game
becoming a dynamic product that
is constantly changing,
giving players
new experiences every day.
The goal of live ops is to
augment engagement, stimulate
monetization, and
reduce player churn.
We see three
components to live ops.
We see content, we
see sales, and events,
and this combination has
proved very successful
for game developers.
Now, in the context of apps, let
me show that with an example.
Memrise-- they're an innovative
language learning app.
Are you guys in the audience?
OK, so an innovative
language learning app
ran a back-to-school offer
in September last year.
To motivate users to start early
when the school year starts,
they released beginner
and advanced versions
of new language combinations
and ran a global campaign
that also offered discounts
for their annual subscription
program.
This was a great
success for them,
and it actually boosted
additional engagement
from this particular
campaign and resulted in
over 32% increase in revenue.
Lastly, and probably
more importantly,
an effective
communication strategy.
That can be a great way to make
users aware of all the features
that can drive engagement.
App push notifications
are not new to anyone.
They're not new to us.
They're not new to us as
a developer or as a user.
And there's so much innovation
happening there now,
and it's a good time to
revisit your strategy
around push notifications.
So let's go through some
of the main characteristics
of good notification.
I say notification,
but these are also
applicable to other
channels of communication,
like in-app messaging, e-mails.
Relevance-- sounds simple.
You want to send messages
that are relevant to the user,
right?
But it can be really hard to
find out what is relevant.
So think about sending
messages that matter
to the user in the
context that they are in.
Be mindful of the tone you use.
Be mindful of the
language that you select.
Also, be creative and
true to your brand.
One way of ensuring that is to
actually give them the option,
to let them select
various alternatives
during the onboarding flow.
Actionable-- notifications
can sometimes
be used to inform, and sometimes
update content, as well
as allow users to
take specific actions.
Whatever action or
info that you want
to show in your
notification, you
want to make sure that
that is also accounted
for in the engagement metrics.
Personalized-- we're not equal.
So are your users.
They are not created equal.
For effective communication,
segment your user base.
Create cohorts and
find customized ways
to tailor your
messaging to them.
Also give them options
to opt in and opt out,
or filter proactively.
Timeliness-- raise your
hands if you have ever
received not important
messages or notifications just
when you're getting to bed.
OK, so right message
at the right time
and at the right frequency
can drive user engagement.
Consider the day of the week.
Consider the time
zone that they're in.
And sometimes you can also give
them one-click alternatives,
like read later.
On Android, rich notifications
are incredibly valuable,
and it's a valuable service that
drives meaningful engagement.
And with every release we are
enhancing the feature set.
Take a look at what
we're launching
with Android O in the preview.
And there are many features
around notifications that are
coming as part of Android O.
So let's take a look
at some examples.
The Guardian-- do not
judge me of the example,
but whatever the
political inclinations
that we have, but let's take
a look at this example, which
is a great example of
how they drove user
engagement with their mobile app
during the recent US election
by using new notifications
functionality in Android N.
They used innovative
techniques to give their users
a rich, real-time update
on the election results
as they happened.
As you can see,
the notifications
are super creative.
They used avatars.
They had a real-time
progress bar
to give you real-time
updates in a creative manner,
and lots of up-to-date results.
The Guardian saw an
impressive engagement
of about 170,000
users who signed up
to see the [INAUDIBLE]
with an average of five
interactions per user.
Another important
characteristic,
as I mentioned before,
is when notifications are
actionable whenever possible.
CityMapper is an app that
gives users smart commute
notifications, and it uses
an FYI, for your information,
type of notifications at the
relevant time for the user.
According to Gilbert Wedam, the
head of design at CityMapper,
notifications on
Android, and therefore
delivering notification
and information right
to the user's log screen,
is such a powerful feature
for them.
Their notification for
daily commute updates
with real-time
information is really
useful for all their users
who are commuting and using
that information
during their commute.
And it's a great way to update
their users on any changes that
take place and drive daily
reengagement to the app.
I want to share another
example of creating relevance
by combining innovative
technologies.
I'm going to highlight Stocard,
who enables you to manage
loyalty cards on your phone.
They use the Awareness
API to notify you
when you're near a chain
store with loyalty points
that you are tracking.
Now, what is Awareness API?
The Awareness API unifies seven
location and contextual signals
into a single API,
enabling you to create
powerful context-based
experiences for your user
with minimal impact
on system resources.
So now you can combine
potentially processed context
signals in new
ways that were not
previously available to
you, while letting the API
manage system resources so
that your app doesn't have to.
Finally, in terms
of tools that you
can use to drive
effective notifications,
I want to highlight
Firebase Notifications.
This is a free
service that enables
targeted user notification
for mobile app developers.
It is based on Firebase
Cloud Messaging,
and provides an option if you
need a flexible notification
system that requires little
in our effort to get started.
They integrate very closely
with Firebase Analytics,
so now you can
target notifications
by customizing audiences.
Now with notifications
targeted to user segments,
you can contact
exactly the right user
at the right time with
updates on available upgrades,
features that you're
launching, or any other news
that you want them to know.
And this works across
Android, iOS, and web.
NIKO SCHROER: Great.
So here we go--
six key areas for you
to optimize your app in
to boost user engagement.
Start with clearly
defining your objective.
Test your features, and
then if you have a winner,
release it smartly.
Leverage the opportunity
that onboarding provides.
It's really a key moment
in the user journey
where you can learn
about users' preferences.
And then strategically
launch content.
And most importantly,
follow all of the superb
tips about effective
notifications
Jeena just provided.
So that is a good list of things
to get right and constantly
improve.
Yet we want to recommend you
add another area to optimize
engagement in your app--
behavioral insights.
It is a super hot
topic, like super hot.
Our expert, Jeni Fisher, put
over one year of research
into it, and covered
this in a dedicated talk
earlier this morning.
So if you didn't get the
chance to check it out yet,
we recommend you to follow
the link on the slides,
and then we're probably going to
put it in the video description
as well, to learn all
about how to leverage
behavioral insights to boost
user engagement and retention.
So we covered a lot of ground
with you today, and really
hope it resonated with you.
What do you think?
Yeah?
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
Thanks.
And we do fully appreciate
that it's a lot of information.
This is day three.
You have heard a lot
of great sessions.
You have watched a lot of
great sessions on livestreams,
I hope.
But as with every session, the
most important thing remains--
what are you going to do
differently after this talk?
What's next?
Well, for today, we want to
make it very easy for you.
We appreciate that it's warm.
You're here.
You want to go out
and enjoy the sun,
or enjoy the rest of
the talks and then
probably have a cool drink.
So for now, all we want you
to do is note down this link--
nothing more.
Write it down, or type it in
your phone, or take a picture.
I will give you a moment
to actually do that.
Cool.
Then you can go and enjoy the
rest of I/O. But on Monday,
or even if it's Sunday,
when you go back to work,
go to the link.
What you will find is our
app engagement checklist
to download.
It helps-- it reminds you of
all the areas you can optimize
to boost user engagement.
And actually, it provides a
set of questions you can use--
you can ask yourself or
you can ask your team
to identify the area and
where your app engagement has
more room for improvement.
So download this and use it.
Go through the
questions, and then
start optimizing
with the tips you
learned today, and,
of course, everything
you learned across the
last couple of days,
and capture the full
opportunity Google Play offers
to you as a developer.
And with that--
JEENA JAMES: Thank you.
NIKO SCHROER: Thank
you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]